two suspensions misdemeanor arrests in
the still pending arson charge dr.
Sinclair represents a school actually is
more of an academy where girls like you
have gone on to do incredible things
welcome to blackboard the consequences
of your actions have brought each of you
here it's an alternative to prison miss
olanski will be collecting of cell
phones that's not fair is this ensure
your choices have been yours in your
saloon your creeper or something no I
was just staring in some bitch's rooms
you do mind keeping it down so who is
there trying to hate this place in peace
we're all thrilled you're here all of
you please enjoy
Cathleen that back to the building is
off-limits to the students
[Music]
there's somebody out there
last night there was something in the
hallway
I'm afraid he'd poorly gets darker Rob
his house
I don't think it's the house
sometimes when the door to the other
side is open it's difficult to control
what comes in dear God no one survives
this place
we're gonna die here Veronica
[Music]
you